for those of you all just tone tuning in
I know some people going damn Whoopi
looks good alright right now I want you
to please welcome Scarlett Johansson
hello
this year I was asked to host the
scientific and technical Awards it was
such an honor to meet the minds behind
the machinery we used to create some of
the most important moments in cinema our
SciTech honors are bestowed at an
exclusive dinner that's one of the
nicest events on the Academy's calendar
following this year's banquet here are
some of the awards that I was delighted
to present the Academy presented its
Award of Merit for the engineering and
development of the luma camera crane and
remote system for motion picture
production if I may say it's like having
a new baby in the family
but this one was a 25 year period of
gestation
I am very very very happy to get this
oscar de la creme is still used today on
prestigious movies like Harry Potter
boy girl with the Pearl Earring and many
many others for the invention continuing
development of the techno crane
telescoping camera crane the Academy's
Award of Merit was presented to force
probably about 20 years ago I try to be
a filmmaker and when I made this film I
made also crane and now I'm very glad
that this crane has this Oscar thank you
the coveted Gordon Sawyer award is
presented to tak Miyagi Shima for a
lifetime of achievement in the science
and technology of don't there must been
others more or just as deserving as I
would be but in saying that I still
accept this so thank you
most of the winners are here tonight so
let's give our congratulations to all of
them